so Bernie Sanders has easily won the
Nevada caucus on Saturday and whatever
you think about the importance of the
Nevada caucus in terms of what does it
mean for the future of the primary what
does it mean for the future of these
candidates it was a clear and decisive
victory for Bernie Sanders Bernie came
away with the victory with 96% reporting
Bernie had 47 percent of the vote as of
about a half hour ago got 13 delegates
Biden got about 20 percent of the vote
and two delegates while mayor Pete Budaj
got the last single delegate with 14
percent of the vote this is by the way a
good example of how you can get the
majority of the delegates without the
majority of the vote Bernie got 46
percent of the votes but ended up with
about 81 percent of the delegates we've
talked about that before I'm sure we'll
talk about it again but what I want to
focus in on is the way that MSNBC and
other establishment media reported on
Bernie's win you would have thought they
were coming to you with the tragic news
of a terrorist attack you would have
thought from the tone tenor and
analogies that were used on MSNBC and
including by some sort of center-left
establishment types on CNN you would
have thought they were commenting on the
tragic death of a thousand children
rather than the victory of a progressive
Democratic candidate who happens to be
Jewish and that'll be relevant as well
I've said before MSNBC is more like Fox
News than you might think they are both
huge corporate profit driven media
channels one is radically and
cartoonishly right-wing editorially the
other MSNBC is establishment Democratic
or you could call it center left period
they have many of the same motivations
Fox News and MSNBC they have many of the
same structural characteristics check
out some of these absolutely wild
reactions on MSNBC to Bernie Sanders win
first is Chris Matthews equating Bernie
Sanders win in
to the Nazi invasion of France I was
reading last night right I know you're a
history guy too
I'm reading last night about the fall of
France in the summer of 1940 and the
general renault calls up Churchill and
says it's over insurances of how can it
be you got the greatest army in Europe
how could it be over he said it's over
so I had that print suppressed feeling I
can't be as wild as Carville but he is
damn smart and I think he's damn right
on this one joy the number of times that
Jewish Bernie Sanders is being compared
or likened in some way shape or form to
Nazis on MSNBC is starting to become a
concerning number Nazis killed family
members of Bernie Sanders MSNBC has at
least twice if not more made references
to Nazis in talking about Bernie or
Bernie supporters a Jewish man wins than
have had a democratic caucus and Chris
Matthews thinks that's kind of like when
Nazis stormed France something is very
wrong here
and whatever your opinion is about
Bernie's medicare-for-all plan right
that's not what this is about this is
too far there are now countless calls
for Chris Matthews to resign from MSNBC
I wouldn't hold my breath
but the insanity of Chris Matthews
equating the wind by a Jewish candidate
to Nazis invading France is stunning
next example from MSNBC's coverage of
Bernie's win in Nevada here's Brian
Williams saying they might kill Bernie
what is he even talking about and the
point Chris made that they're gonna kill
him but they may not stop him come
Monday they're gonna kill him they may
not stop again what on earth is Brian
Williams talking about and what is the
prudency of starting to allude to
wanting to kill a candidate who will no
doubt if he is the nominee partially
because of his ideology partially
because of his Jewish heritage will be
extraordinarily targeted by very violent
factions of the political world here is
example number three Chris Jansing an
MSNBC reporter with an audible drum
maduk sigh of disdain as she realizes
that at her particular caucus location
bernie has the lion's share of support
listen to that sigh these again are
people who work on the strip within two
and a half miles of the Bellagio largely
people of color of those the majority
are Latino and they are clearly at least
from eyeballing it strongly in favor of
Bernie Sanders with Joe Biden coming in
second and I could do more and more of
these I could do five or ten minutes of
highlights of you know joy Reed making
absolutely no sense with her
establishment theatrics but this is what
we're seeing and the reason we're seeing
it is it it's because of the fear that
establishment center-left media has if
Bernie Sanders were to be President even
if Bernie Sanders were to be nominee if
it's Trump who's the president
center-left obviously as opposed to
Donald Trump you've got a clear and
concise and narrow direct path as to
what your editorial policy will be for
maximum profit it's all very cut and dry
if you have a center-left
nominee like Biden or Buda edge 2020
version of Buda jej 2018 Budaj edge was
much more like Bernie but we have 2020
Budaj edge or Amy Klobuchar somebody
like that Bloomberg it's very clear what
you do you support them and they are not
really going to do anything to radically
challenge your place of privilege in
society and in the economy so that's
very clear what does the establishment
center-left media do what do these
bloggers and people like you know
Jennifer Rubin and others what do they
do if you have Bernie Sanders the
nominee or even Elizabeth Warren the
nominee what do they do
throughout the general election what do
they do if someone like Bernie or Warren
were to become president of the United
States I actually don't know the answer
they knew we were on the left so we're
against the right but we also don't want
the progressive left what do they do
they are seeing the potential crumbling
of their entire the entire
infrastructure that
supports their model could crumble and
they know it so the Democratic
establishment knows it the center-left
legacy media know it they don't know how
to position themselves I anticipate it
will get even weirder just during what's
remaining in the primary and then once
we get to the general election it's
going to be an absolute madhouse we are
starting to see the preview here one of
our sponsors today is VIN Chara watches
giving you 15% off your entire order
when you go to david pakman.com slash
watch don't pay thousands of dollars for
a high-quality watch that looks great
because you don't have to all of inch
arrows watches are made with high-end
materials masterfully built and they
look like something you'd spend a ton of
money on but ever even chera watch
ranges from about a hundred and fifty to
three hundred bucks I went over to their
website and picked out the bellwether
and silver and white really nice elegant
look it's a coronagraph style wore it to
a gala over the weekend and a lot of
people ask me where's the watch from
really really great look totally
different they also sent me the altitude
in matte black and red a much more
rugged view of what a watch can look
like really liked it as well as well as
the athletic strap it's a new year it's
a new decade it's time to re-establish
your style add something new to your
look and a high-quality watch is the
perfect way to do that you can get 15%
off inch arrows entire collection when
you go to david pakman.com slash watch